l'informatique et l'emploi voilà
maintenant le thème que nous voudrions
abordé ce soir en plein sicob jusqu
alors en effet notre enquête assez
poussées sur la télématique c'est à dire
le mariage de l'ordinateur la télévision
et du téléphone de nous intéressions à
la mine eu ni à théorisation à la
démocratisation de l'ordinateur et à ses
incidences sur les libertés seulement il
n'y a pas que ça il ya aussi les
conséquences de ces bouleversements sur
l'emploi et là les avis sont très
partagés
regardez plutôt l'enquète de jean-marc
il use et de pierreries se chargeant le
clavier sera bientôt l'outil universel
c'est à dire souvent le seul
intermédiaire entre l'homme et la
machine
qu'il s'agisse d'un primaire un texte ou
de faire travailler un robot dans
l'automobile l'ordinateur va supprimer
les tâches répétitives comme il supprime
déjà largement dans les banques par
exemple les manipulations de paperasse
songé deux milliards et demi de chèques
échangés chaque année soit 2500 tonnes
de papier sans compter les bordereaux
annexes 1400 minutes l'ordinateur
central trash les rouleaux les 30 pour
l'alimenter près de deux tiers des 45
mille salariés du crédit lyonnais
utilise déjà de manière systématique
tout temporaire les services
d'ordinateurs parce qu'elle a coïncidé
avec une période de triplement des
activités bancaires cette première
informatisation s'est faite sans
licenciement mais sera-t-il possible
demain de concilier ralentissement
économique et multiplication des postes
informatisée sans toucher à l'emploi
au plan des personnels bancaire
traditionnel
l'informatisation peut entraîner
effectivement des économies de postes
mais en contrepartie au sein même de
l'établissement
nous facilitons et nous organisons la
reconversion de certains nos
collaborateurs nous modifions certaines
de nos structures ce qui nous permet
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
nous utilisons les mouvements naturels
de personnel c'est-à-dire des missions
retraite
malgré cette conjoncture économique
difficile pour tout le monde
à défaut de pouvoir embaucher comme hier
on affirme donc ne pas licencier demain
c'est vrai les pentes ont largement
amorcé la reconversion informatique de
certains personnels leur budget
formation est souvent important résultat
dans ce centre administratif 66
personnes suffisent à traiter 200 milles
chèque par jour écriture traditionnels
ou recourent à l'ordinateur
chacun peut accomplir des tâches
diversifiées souvent jugée moins
astreignante
josette la mécanographie c'est à dire
tous les traitements comme celui ci mais
en machines beaucoup plus simple
c'est plus fatigant
nous ne sommes pas contre l'informatique
disent les syndicats mais il faut être
vigilant
l'étape actuelle n'est qu'un
intermédiaire progressivement le travail
sera pré mâchée par les petits
ordinateurs et les qualifications rogner
en douceur on nous prépare un tout
informatique
les patrons banquiers recherche
actuellement d'autres voies de
développement de l'informatique comme le
guichet automatique ou le client comme
aujourd'hui
il s'adresse à un distributeur
automatique de billets pour obtenir
quelques billets pour à part lui même
réalisée directement un certain nombre
d'opérations qui nécessitent aujourd'hui
la présence de guichetiers
c'est donc l'emploi dans sa globalité
dans les banques qui est menacée pour le
futur numériquement par des dizaines de
milliers d'employés et ola la
qualification une banque comme la baie à
une petite vente régional a déjà mis en
place un certain nombre de guichets
automatiques et prévoit des réductions
de personnel qui seraient reclassés dans
d'autres banques
que se passera-t-il quand toutes les
banques seront au même état d'évolutions
ses appréhensions syndicales se
retrouvent dans l'ensemble des services
ils ont été les premiers informatisés
mais aussi les premiers créateurs
d'emplois ces dernières années
aujourd'hui l'informatique fait déjà
vivre trois cent mille personnes
constructeurs et surtout utilisateurs
demain pour mieux produire mieux
exporter il faudra encore informatisé
certains emplois seront supprimés
l'informatique pourra-t-elle assez vite
en créer de nouveaux ce chiffre pour ma
part à 300 mille le nombre de
disparitions de postes de travail d'ici
1985 il se passionne pas ce travail ça
ne signifie pas obligatoirement
licenciements mais sûrement arrêt de
laon gauche au moment où vous le savez
240 mille jeunes arrivent chaque année
sur le marché du travail mais il y aura
quand même des créations d'emploi bien
sûr une dizaine de milliers environ chez
les constructeurs et puis surtout à
environ 100 milles dans les services
saleh qui lie à environ 150 milles
réparateurs automobiles
il va falloir aussi beaucoup de
réparateurs de ces nouvelles machines
télématique
cela dit le bilan est quand même plutôt
négatif
trois cent mille contre 100 milles ce
qui signifie qu'il faut développer donc
créer des emplois dans toutes les
nouvelles technologies électroniques par
exemple les circuits intégrés
parce qu'elles sont les garants de
l'avenir de l'emploi de demain
aux etats unis les fabricants de
circuits intégrés emploie déjà cent
mille personnes et pour robotisée ses
chaînes de production automobile la
general motors dépensera cette année
concurrence oblige 30 milliards de
francs